So of course, traditionally, photographers used the aperture, shutter, and
focal length values of the camera to extensively be able to define how
they want to be able to take, and what kind of pictures they want to take.
I'm just going to show you a few examples that I found just to kind of
show the value of this kind of stuff.
Here, shallow depth of field is shown by how the pictures are taken,
things are right there are perfectly in focus.
These are not that far behind, but they seem to be a little bit out of focus.
So this is the concept of shallow depth of field.
Motion blur, here you can see, for
example, the birds are showing motion because of shutter speed changes.
You can see that the wings are blurred.
Here you can see the hand is blurred but the text is not.
And of course traditional effects of light streaking at nights and
stuff like are again because shutter is kept open a little longer.
And of course when the cars move have this impact.
And, of course, there's a whole tradition of people doing light art.
I found this beautiful site that I point here that actually if you want you
can look at on your own.
It shows a lot of fun things that you can do with just how you can control and
how you can play around with light.